[computer mouse clicking]
[upbeat piano music]
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bi-pedal, naked, large brained,
long the master of fire,
tools, and language
but still trying to understand ourselves,
aware that death is inevitable
yet filled with optimism,
we grow up slowly,
we hand down knowledge,
we empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our
shared understanding of the past.
Carta brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who
we are and how we got here,
an exploration made possible by
the generosity of humans like you.
[upbeat electronic music]
- Okay, so I'm an old low ranking male
so that means I should be good at hunting
(laughter)
but it kind of depresses me to think
that the measure of success
is how good a hunter we are.
I'm a vegetarian, well almost,
so that's what I'd like to be,
but still it's an important
issue so let's talk about this.
I want to talk about the
origins of what I'll call
the Human Predatory
Pattern, and the reason
I'm calling it that is because that's what
Jessica Thompson and
colleagues are calling it
in a paper in press in
Current Anthropology
emphasizing the fact that Hominins
are killing animals
larger than themselves.
Chimps can kill animals the
same size of themselves,
namely other adult Chimpanzees,
but they don't eat them
and humans of course,
are different in this respect.
So, the standard kind of model
which is in someways the justification
for the material we've been
hearing about Chimpanzees,
is that you have a lost common ancestor
that was hunting in the Chimp-style
and then out of that comes
the Human Predatory Pattern
and then a slight modification of that
comes from people like
the Jessica Thompson team
and I think, Briana,
where you can have that
chimp-style hunting and then,
in the Australopithecine era
they may or may not be hunting very much,
difficult for them to catch red colobus,
not to many around in the Savannah,
but still interested in
meat and animal products,
and then out of that you
get maybe an interest in
fat-processing, from the
marrow and other organs,
and out of that, coming the
scavenging then hunting,
but here's my point, all of this
assumes that the stuff is eaten raw.
Well that conforms to conventional wisdom.
Conventional wisdom
sees Australopithecines
giving rise to Homo erectus
then Homo heidelbergensis
and finally, the finest
kind of human you can have,
represented here by the
President of Harvard,
(laughter)
emerging out of the President of Yale
and the point of course
is that the standard story
is that this was raw
meat that was responsible
for this big transformation,
nothing much happening
after we get Homo erectus,
and that fire comes in
some time quite a lot
later, and maybe that's true
but I doubt it myself, I think
that fire came in earlier
but what is certainly
true is that raw meat
is a difficult food for people nowadays.
It's rare to find hunters and gatherers
eating raw meat at all as you see
from this survey around the world
and in Africa, there is no
record of people eating raw meat
and to the extent that we have data
on what happens when
people do eat raw meat,
which we have to go to urban raw-foodists,
people who are able to survive
on supermarkets and so on.
What you find following the red line here
is that raw food is a
great way of losing weight.
It shows that you lose body mass index
quite predictably by eating
a lot of your diet raw
and this includes both vegans and
people who are eating their meat raw.
And then the blue line shows you that
raw food is quite a good
contraceptive, too, because
(laughter)
by the time you're eating
50 percent of your food raw,
if you are a woman, sorry,
100 percent of your food raw,
50 percent chance of having
your reproductive system
totally shut down and
that is despite the fact
that they're eating just
about as high quality
of a raw diet as you can imagine
and having no seasonal stresses and so on.
It's quite clear that
cooking does something.
It increases the energy value, we know,
for starch and protein and plant lipids.
Now here is the fact
that you should remember
among, beyond anything else
that I'm going to say today,
nobody knows what the consequence
is of cooking animal fats.
We do know about cooking plant lipids,
that it increases the
digestibility of the plant lipids,
you get more energy value out of it,
but no one has done it with animal fats,
which is crazy, and if
you think about the fact
of how much more delicious
a lump of suet is
when it's been cooked,
then it seems very likely
that you're food perception system is tied
to the consequences
biologically in your body,
but the fact is that were not sure
so it seems very likely that
raw meat has got low value
compared to both cooked meat,
I mean that's what we do know,
and a point I want to say here, is marrow.
What I want to emphasize here is that
the consequences of cooking meat
are very substantially beneficial.
The consequences of cooking marrow
with its fat content may be a bit less,
so we'll think about
this in terms of safety
and palatability and time to ingest.
I'm not going to talk about digestibility
and the cost of digestion
because we don't know anything
in terms of the marrows
so that's really crazy,
one of the most important foods
probably in human evolution,
fat from animals, and
cooking, the signature feature
of the human diet, and yet we don't know
what the consequence is of
cooking fat for the energy gain.
Alright, so we know cooking
is biologically important.
We know it raises the food value,
probably does it differently
for different foods.
I want to propose
something that will annoy
several of my colleagues which is
that before cooking Hominin
meat-eating was less important
and Hominin fat-eating was more important.
So the first thing I want to say is about
the dangers of eating from a dead zebra
that you happen to find there.
It is disgusting.
(laughter)
Sonia Ragir pointed out some time ago
that the meat is
dangerous when you find it
because of bacterial
growth and Alex Smith,
in my lab did some nice experiments
showing that if you compare
the rate of bacterial growth
on raw meat compared to
marrow, that it grows
much faster on raw meat
and whereas if you cook it
then it's safe for very quickly
and internal marrow is really safe
so meat you can sometimes get away with
cutting outside bits in, off,
and taking what's inside,
but even then, it decays pretty quickly
and it is going to remain rather dangerous
which I think is why chimpanzees,
by the way, don't scavenge much.
If there was implication earlier
that they sort of don't
recognize dead meat as food,
I think they do, it's just that
they're pretty cautious about it
and occasionally they
do, they do scavenge.
Okay, so here's my major
point I want to make,
that Hominins without
fire couldn't hunt much
cause there's just not
much time for hunting.
So here is the data on the amount of time
that chimpanzees spend feeding
which is incredibly frustrating
to teams from National Geographic
that come and want to see
chimps doing fancy things,
cause in fact all they do is sit there
eating most of the time
and there's variation
among the sites and
the ones at the bottom,
Bassou, they're eating
quite a lot of human foods
dug up from fields, that sort of thing,
but overall, we got, close
on, 50 percent of their day
is spent literally just chewing
and that means that they
can't do other things,
such as write poetry or go hunting.
(laughter)
So here what we've got is a strange plot
of the distribution of time spent feeding
in non-human primates and you see
there's a pretty steady
rise as body size increases
on the bottom axis and so by the time
you are a Homo you should be eating,
for something like chewing,
for something like 50
to actually slightly higher
than 50 percent of the day.
That's what you should
be doing, but you're not
and in fact, what humans do is
they chew for less than an hour a day.
It's a relatively trivial time
and meat eating does not help that much
if you are a raw eater,
so here is some estimates
that is difficult to get normally
for how much total time
it takes to chew a carcass
because it's relatively
rare that you can see
all the different bits of the carcass
and how much they have
been eaten by chimps
but this suggests that when you take,
for instance, a baboon that
weighs a certain amount
and you estimate 80
percent of it was eaten,
and you total up all
the eating that was done
during that period that you could see
is a total of 9 chimpanzee-hours
and the net result is
that you're eating meat
at about the rate that you are some of the
higher quality fruits in
terms of calorie intake.
There's a note here saying that Ian Gilby
thinks that I'm underestimating
the rate of eating
and I'm sure I'm underestimating
it from the initial phase
of eating, when they're
eating the softer bits,
but we have yet to get
very good data on this,
so it may turn out that the
underestimate is important,
but nevertheless, that's
what we got so far.
Chimps don't hunt for very long at a time.
Here you see some estimates,
all between 15 minutes
and half an hour, that sort of thing,
if they get into a hunt, and after that,
there, they give up.
This is not effected by how
often they're overall killing,
there's this big range
that we've seen before,
sometimes like one a month
and sometimes ten a month,
but nevertheless, they're
always having this low rate,
this low duration of the
hunt and you can see why,
here is how the feeding
time is distributed
in a particular individual
from dawn until dusk.
The red is when he's chewing,
so there's just not much time
between chewing, and by the way,
when they stop chewing,
what are they doing?
They're mostly lying around in order
to be able to digest the food.
(laughter)
So the typical pattern
is, you go up into a tree,
you eat for 45 minutes,
then you come and lie down,
(laughter)
and then wait for the
stomach to be emptied,
and then you go up again, that's
what seems to be happening.
So there's variation among chimps
and here's a bunch of different days,
you see some days there
is very little time
to do anything other than
eat and sometimes more
and it bounces out across days and so on,
but you can look at this and you can say,
okay let's look at the
inter-feeding interval.
How much time is there
between what you gotta do,
which is to get food into your belly,
and the answer is that
the median is 20 minutes,
the mean of 40 minutes,
this is old data from Gombe
but that compares with
the mean hunt duration
of quarter of an hour, half an hour,
so it's about the same
and the implication here
is that if you are chewing a lot,
there's just no time to
go hunting, so sorry.
Now humans, obviously we're much
less constrained by eating time
and actually funnily
enough there is no paper
that has looked at when humans eat,
but this looks like a
very confident assertion
that among hunter-gatherers
only one regular meal
is eaten in camp, and it's the night after
the people have returned
from the day's hunting.
That's the sort of typical pattern,
particularly as you go into
the earlier ethnographies.
Humans are able to spend
long hours during the day,
on the hunt, and here you see distribution
across different hunter gatherer societies
for men and women, and the
men are spending on average,
just over four hours a
day, which means that
it is possible for them to
do something that chimpanzees
could not possibly do,
and therefore, I think,
that a raw meat-eating Hominin
could not have done either.
Meanwhile, could they
go out and track around
looking for their food, foraging, hunting?
Dan Lieberman and his colleague Bramble
have drawn attention to
a whole bunch of features
in our skeletons which indicate that Homo
is uniquely derived an ability to have
endurance walking or endurance running
tramping around across the Savannah
looking for opportunities to
either scavenge or to kill.
Well that doesn't seem very easy
if you've got a great big belly
that we've just been hearing
about with those flared ribs
and you're keeping it full
of stuff all the time.
So you're asking a gorilla
full of vegetation,
as it were, to go running
off two or three hours.
I don't think so.
I think they, one reason, is
that you've got a large gut
and that large gut is full for a
tremendous amount of the time and then,
I actually think there's
probably another reason,
this is a little speculative admittedly,
but I think that the creatures before fire
would have needed to keep
warm at night with hair,
and as long as they had to do that,
then they couldn't lose
heat easily during a day,
so it's very difficult for me to imagine
an endurance runner in particular
being able to do that before fire.
Okay, so what I'm saying so far,
is that meat eating would have been
less extensive before the control of fire,
because of the lack of
safety in the raw meat
and the fact of chewing for so long
meant that you had also
large guts full of food,
you couldn't run and hunt, and I suspect
when we know about it,
that the relative value
of raw meat compared to raw fat
is going to be relatively low.
Okay, so what did Hominins
eat before cooking
because I do think that
it's reasonable to imagine
that there's been a phase in which
Hominins were using animal
products before cooking
and the safe bit are the ones
that are enclosed in bone
and that would be marrow or brain
from below the exposed surfaces
is what you want to do and certainly,
marrow is an important food
for the hunter gatherers.
Here is data for the
Hadza and how many of them
are eaten raw, so by the time
you're eating big animals
like buffalo, James Oliver
finds that 80 percent,
or 70 to 80 percent of the
limb bones are eaten raw
so that all seems just fine
but there would be a difference
if you're eating them
raw from eating cooked
because nowadays there
is an ability to use
both the marrow in the shaft of the bone
and the fat in the trebecula bone
or the cancellous bone area which you,
very difficult to get
out just with your teeth,
you really have to boil it up
to be able to release the grease
and until you have cooking, you're not
going to be able to use that very much.
And then there's a difference
in the kind of marrow
that is going to be preferred.
Binford showed very nicely that there is
a good relationship between the degree of
unsaturated fat in the
marrow and the preference.
Here you see, for the Inuit
people that he was studying,
that the more unsaturated marrow there is,
then the more the bone is preferred,
so unsaturated is much
nicer than saturated fat
when it's eaten raw, and
that is probably because
it has got a lower melting point,
and with a lower melting point,
it probably, I think it'll turn out,
will turn out to have a
lower cost of digestion,
because the body is going
to have to work less hard
to reduce it to the tiny, tiny particles
just a few angstroms across that have to
be reduced before it can go
across the intestinal wall.
So, where are the unsaturated fats found?
They are found more at the
nether ends of the limbs
so if you take a typical ungulate foreleg
you find that the saturated
fats tend to be richer
close to the shoulder and
throughout the axial skeleton
and the unsaturated fats are
richer at the distal parts
which nobody understands why that is,
I mean, there's the sort of suggestion
well, unsaturated fats
having lower melting points,
they're maybe sort of more flexible,
they may allow more flexibility,
but that's being a bit speculative.
Okay, so, preference for unsaturated fats,
and then there's the question of brains,
so the limb marrow is
great for most of the year,
but you see here in a couple of examples
that femur marrow is very poor during
periods of the year when the
animals are in poor condition.
Going right down to 20 percent fat
and that's a point
mirroring what's happening
with the kidney fat,
at which you can expect
that there will be rejection of the food
and so here's a claims from Binford,
saying that if the Caribou is in
too poor condition,
you break open the bone
and it's soft and runny, then no, goodbye.
During those periods,
brains should be okay.
Here is Kim Hill saying that he loved,
well, he's saying that
the Ache and the Hiwi,
hunter gatherers in Paraguay and Venezuela
love brains and he says, grossly,
that he loved it himself.
I asked him if he had it raw, he said no
but you could, as long
as it's reasonably fresh,
you know there is decay that goes on.
Of course, the problem with brains
is that they're hard to extract
and if you're a Hominin they're embedded
very often with things with horns,
and the skull is really heavy,
so it's not that great, but it is good
because the quality of
the fat always stays high
and it's the last thing
that you will lose fat from,
and then, goodbye.
(laughter)
So, my conclusion is that if
the early Homo diets were raw,
then you've got to put up with the notion
that there was extensive chewing,
minimal time for hunting, and I think,
no endurance running
and they would be eating
particularly from the fat-rich areas
and there'd be more marrow
than in cooked diets,
there'd be more marrow
especially from the distal bones,
and especially from the brain.
So overall, more scavenging,
more fat, and less meat.
Overall, the kind of concept
that I was referring to earlier
of chimpanzee-style hunting giving rise
to an interest in animal products
and then percussive fat-processing,
breaking open those limb-bones,
and then finally getting
the Human Predatory Pattern,
that seems to me a great
way to think about things,
and then we should think
about the first three stages
as involving raw meat, but I don't think
you can go very far into the fourth
without making it cooked, so
I have a different concept
of the Harvard and the Yale Presidents.
(laughter)
Thank you.
(applause)
[upbeat electronic music]